IMAGES.
AND BILL MELUGIN, THANK YOU.
GRIFF.
GRIFF: ANITA AND BILL FOR MORE
ON THIS, WE'LL BE JOINED BY
ACTING ICE DIRECTOR TOM HOMAN.
AND YOU HEARD BILL'S GREAT
REPORTING AND JUST MENTIONING
IN DEL RIO SECTOR THIS FISCAL
YEAR ESSENTIALLY 30 DAYS,
50,000 IN JUST DEL RIO.
BORDER-WIDE I'VE BEEN TOLD IT'S
200,000.
SEEMS THAT THINGS ARE NOT
SLOWING DOWN.
>> AND MY SOURCES SAYS ABOUT
210,000, 30 TO 50,000, AND A
QUARTER MILLION.
A QUARTER MILLION PEOPLE IN ONE
MONTH.
THE SCARIEST NUMBER IS 86,000
GOT-AWAYS.
LAST MONTH 86,000 PEOPLE
ENTERED THIS COUNTRY.
DIDN'T TURN THEMSELVES IN, TO
CLAIM ASYLUM AND BE RELEASED.
THEY AVOIDED APPREHENSION, THE
ROAN THEY DIDN'T DO THAT.
AND DIDN'T WANT TO BE
FINGERPRINTED, AND BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN DRUGS, FENTANYL, OR
TERRORISTS.
AND THEY'RE COMING FROM
COUNTRIES MANY OF THEM SPONSORS
OF TERRORISM.
86,000 PEOPLE ENTERED THE
COUNTRY AND GOT AWAY.
WHY?
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
TERRORISTS CROSSED THE BORDER
WE DON'T THINK THAT A SINGLE
ONE CAME FROM A COUNTRY
SPONSORING TERROR?
THIS IS THE BIGGEST SECURITY
DISASTER SINCE 9/11.
GRIFF: AND HOW IMPORTANT TO
THIS MIDTERM ELECTION, TOM, IS
THE BORDER ISSUE, IS WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH THE
NATIONAL SECURITY RISK?
>> I'M HOPING PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING BEYOND.
AGAIN, REGARDLESS WHAT THEIR
OPINION IS ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, THEY NEED TO LOOK
BEYOND.
THIS CRISIS IS SO BIG, UP TO
80% OF BORDER PATROL OFFICERS
HAVE BEEN CALLED OFF TO
PROCESS.
AND THAT'S THE FENNEL NIL AND
THE MI13 AND THE CRIMINAL
ISSUE.
SINCE JOE BIDEN HAS TAKEN
OFFICE, MORE THAN ONE MILLION
GET-AWAYS, ONE MILLION PEOPLE
DIDN'T WANT TO TURN THEMSELVES
IN.
AND LAST MONTH 86,000, SPREAD
THAT OUT OVER 12 MONTHS, THAT'S
ONE MILLION GOT-AWAYS.
IT'S A HUGE NATIONAL SECURITY
CONCERN AND I HOPE THE VOTERS
REMEMBER THAT.
>> IF IT'S A BIG ENOUGH ISSUE,
PLACES LIKE ARIZONA, FOR
EXAMPLE, IN TUCSON PIMA VOTES
HEAVILY DEMOCRAT, BUT ENOUGH
CROSSOVER PUT SOMEONE THIS,
LIKE BLAKE MASTERS AND KARI
LAKE AND REPUBLICANS IN HOVES,
WHAT DO YOU HOPE THEY DO.
>> TAKE IT BACK TO THE HOUSE
AND SENATE, AND PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS THE POWER OF THE EXECUTIVE
PEN, BUT NOW WE HAVE THE POWER
OF THE PURSE.
A COUPLE OF THINGS, WE CAN STOP
THE RIDICULOUS LEGISLATION AND
STILL GOING TO DO EXECUTIVE
ACTION, BUT WE CAN HOLD THIS
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE,
LOOK, IF YOU DON'T DO
SOMETHING, TAKE STEPS TO SECURE
THIS BORDER AND SECRETARY'S GOT
TO STOP LYING ABOUT SECURITY
BORDER.
86,000 ESCAPEES IS NOT, AND
THEN SHUT IT DOWN.
100,000 AMERICANS DEAD.
86,000 PEOPLE CROSSING THE
BORDER LAST MONTH THAT WEREN'T
ARRESTED AT WHAT POINT IS
ENOUGH ENOUGH?
WE'VE GOT OVER 1400 MIGRANTS--
>> IF THE REPUBLICANS TAKE THE
HOUSE, LOOKS LIKE AT LEAST
AND/OR THE SENATE AND TRY TO
DRAW UP IMPEACHMENT PAPERS ON
SECRETARY MAYORKAS?
>> ABSOLUTELY, ON DAY ONE, THAT
MAN HAS VIOLATED THE OATH OF
OFFICE HE TOOK, LIED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PERJURY IN FRONT OF CONGRESS
WHEN HE SAID THE BORDER IS
SECURE, AND THE COUNTRY IS LESS
SAFE.
TAYE ONE HE NEED